you probably heard about the protest
plans of Amazon employees to walk out on
prime day and fight against terrible
working conditions on Amazon while this
will only last a couple of hours these
few hours could end up costing Amazon
tens of millions of dollars as it is
actually during prime day one of
Amazon's best selling days of the year
in fact last year the company sold over
100 million products and garnered tens
of millions of additional prime numbers
on this day and damn mention that
primary oil lasted 36 hours last year
which has since been increased to 48
hours this year and what about the
hundreds of thousands of unhappy
customers who won't get their packages
delivered on time as they wouldn't have
been shipped on time from the warehouse
fortunately these consequences won't be
too bad as while large these losses can
be sustained by a company as large as
Amazon and the other happy customers
will mostly forget about it and move on
but what if this wasn't a temporary
issue what if Amazon completely shut
down today maybe this is because the US
government got so fed up with Amazon not
paying sales taxes that instead of
issuing a fine or modifying the tax laws
they completely shut down Amazon Howard
Amazon shutting down affect our lives
today the first and probably most
significant issue that comes to cite is
job loss over 650,000 people would lose
their jobs mostly in the US this would
be so significant that the national
unemployment rate would increase from
the all-time lows of 3.6 to 3.7 percent
to 4 percent while this may not sound
like a lot this is actually 11 percent
increase this massive increase of
unemployed people will no doubt lead to
an increase in government spending for
unemployment benefits by hundreds and
millions of dollars and with tax rates
being slashed just a couple of years ago
the government would be forced to borrow
money cut back spending on other regions
or of course increased the tax rate to
make matters even worse with Amazon
being such a large corporation the
overall GDP of the u.s. itself will
noticeably decrease GDP or gross
domestic product is the total value of
final goods and services produced within
a country's borders and it is calculated
by summing together total private
consumption and growth and investment
government spending and exports and then
subtract import from all of that Amazon
pulls in over 200
involves revenue every single year which
is all either domestic consumer spending
exports to other countries or investment
from other companies for Amazon
offerings like their cloud system AWS so
a decrease in all these categories will
decrease the u.s. GDP on the bright side
imports would also decrease but that's
not nearly enough to offset the decrease
in the other categories and that's just
a direct impact of Amazon shutting down
there will also be long-term indirect
effects on the GDP as well think about
the 650,000 employees that were fired
and all of their families they won't be
spending nearly as much as they are now
until they're well settled into a new
job which could take several months all
of this will decrease the US GDP by
hundreds of billions of dollars maybe
even upwards of one trillion dollars now
that's a pretty significant portion when
you consider the u.s. GDP as nineteen
point three nine trillion dollars to
prevent massive losses in GDP the
government will significantly increase
spending and try to combat these
decreases but that can only go so far
and despite their efforts the US GDP is
bound to decrease a couple of percentage
points with the Amazon so what's the big
deal is just a couple of percentage
points right well even a slight decrease
in GDP can impact currency exchange rate
purchasing power and most importantly
consumer confidence and simple terms
foreign goods will increase in price and
people will be less likely to spend
money which can lead to an additional
decrease in GDP
this type of repeated cycles actually
what leads to a depression like in 2008
but fortunately for us while Amazon is a
massive company it is not big enough
that the US economy itself would
collapse and enter depression without
them that being said this will lead to a
pretty deep troph in the business cycle
graph and this accompanied with some
other factors like that trade work could
result in devastating consequences and
that's not even considering the impact
on Amazon sellers and the repercussions
of that as well in just the first seven
months of 2019 Amazon has increased its
sell account by 1.3 million sellers
clearly most of these people don't even
end up listing a product but there are
1.7 million sellers with products listed
for sale of these people 140,000
third-party sellers and over $100,000 in
revenue every single year which equates
to a pretty deep
salary all of these sellers will have to
migrate to eBay Etsy or some other third
Priceline website where they may not
find nearly as much success as there
will be a lot of new obstacles a lot of
these letters will be used to Amazon
fulfilling all of their orders and while
the fees may be something to complain
about that convenience is truly
extraordinary Amazon handles everything
from receiving inventory to ensuring
that the part is delivered to the
customer on time they even handle
returns and customer service but here
sellers will either have to find a
third-party fulfillment service or take
shipping into your own hands a lot of
these sellers will definitely not be up
to these tasks and end up liquidating
their inventory and moving back into a
day job or focus on something else like
stock or real estate investing plus if
Amazon were to disappear only a portion
of their sales traffic will end up in
other online websites the rest of the
demand will shift towards retail stores
or just disappear into thin air that's a
lot of things people purchase online are
things they really don't need in the
first place so logistically
not all successful sellers on Amazon
will be able to continue in their
entrepreneurial ventures without Amazon
fortunately for retailers however this
would reignite a good amount of interest
in visiting physical retail stores and
this would be good and bad at the same
time we killed giants like Walmart
Target and Best Buy to have adapted to
the online trend and transitioned our
stores to more of a junction point for
shaping up online orders and handling
returns we'll have to take a lot of
steps backwards
they will have to spend more money on
more employees to run checkout and help
customers and pay more people to restock
shelves as there's more demand and of
course all of these will increase cost
for these retailers and will lead to an
increase in in-store prices if you
haven't noticed already price online for
all of these retailers are cheaper than
in-store I think it is self-explanatory
why online prices would be cheaper while
these retailers do offer packs matching
with their online prices they are paying
that most customers won't actually
follow through with this this is because
the prices are not vastly different for
most products usually less than $1 but
as you get into more expensive products
you may start to see a meaningful
difference so while to death of Amazon
would be good for retailers as there
would be increased traffic to their
online and physical stores this would
negatively affect the consumer as
would be more expensive in store and as
a matter of fact online as well due to
significantly reduced competition plus I
think that the retailers or at least the
successful retailers have adapted to
recent trends would actually prefer you
buy on their websites anyways as it
saves them money as well on top of all
of this consumer convenience would also
drastically be impacted as people would
have to change a lot of their daily
habits people would have to change where
they shop online and they may have to
deal with slower shaping times everyone
watching prime video would have to
switch over to Netflix or Hulu and
Kindle owners were no longer received
updates and everyone used to LexA will
eventually have to switch over to Google
or to Siri or Cortana fortunately there
are plenty of alternatives but it is an
inconvenience nonetheless these are all
just impact on the US consumers but what
about the effects on companies well the
industry Amazon is directly linked to is
the mail industry as they will have to
ship all of their products Amazon has
started to handle lot of their own
shipments in order to increase
efficiency and reduce shipping costs but
billions of dollars of shipping still go
to UPS FedEx DHL and USPS eventually
this change would have still occurred
but it would have been much more gradual
and predictable shipping carriers would
have been able to scale back accordingly
and prevent millions of dollars of
sudden losses they could cut back on
unprofitable routes and focus in
different areas but if this change were
to happen unexpectedly they won't be
able to prevent unnecessary losses okay
so with all these losses everywhere
these devastating losses must carry on
too Jeff Bezos and all the investors in
Amazon - right well yes and no first of
all just because Amazon shuts down
doesn't mean that their stock price will
drop to zero
Amazon's market cap is just a little shy
of one trillion dollars and wildlife
that value is derived from their
services they actually have one or
seventy eight billion dollars worth of
assets this includes things like their
planes trucks were houses equipment
acquisitions like Whole Foods and Twitch
and subsidiaries as well so even if
amazon.com itself were to shut down
these assets was doubly liquefiable and
could be paid out to stock investors if
needed even if they were only able to
sell all their assets for 150 billion
dollars all their shareholders would be
fine we take into consideration that
present Amazon
talk which is currently over $2,000 it
is clear that all serious talk investors
with a significant amount of money would
be investing in Amazon and Amazon will
be by no way definitive of their wealth
or well-being
so even if they were to completely lose
her Amazon stock they really wouldn't be
affected very much and as for Jeff Bezos
the largest stockholder of Amazon even
he only owns 60% of Amazon so if Amazon
were to be liquidated at 150 billion
dollars which is very conservative he
would still receive twenty four billion
dollars pre-tax and Plus Amazon isn't
the only place he keeps his money in
fact Jeff Bezos has been lit creating
one billion loss of stock every single
year to help fund his space company Blue
Origin so while Jeff besos may lose more
money than what the second richest
person has this will actually not affect
him very much at all in terms of
lifestyle as he would still be one of
the wealthiest people on the planet so
yes Jeff Bezos and Amazon stock
investors will lose a lot of money but
would it matter not really thus if
Amazon were to shut down it would
actually be the American people who
would be affected that most executives
and stockholders will walk away without
much of a noticeable difference as they
usually are able to with the best
example of this being toys-r-us
executives it will be the hundreds of
thousands of ordinary Amazon employees
that'll be displaced there will be the
US economy that will decline it will be
a shipping companies that Amazon has
arguably taken advantage of that will
have to restructure their system even if
for some reason Amazon executives
workers lose all their money they are
just a couple of people and the effect
of the disappearance of Amazon will be
much greater on the US public than any
of them it is the public that will have
to deal with the declining economy as
well as reduced competition and
increased prices in a variety of
different niches from online shopping to
video streaming
fortunately the government is well aware
of all of these potential negative
effects and as a result we will not be
seeing a shutdown at least not a
government induced shutdown of Amazon
anytime soon
in the end Amazon has grown to affect
our lives in more ways than we consider
and today a world without Amazon would
actually be much worse for us than it
would be for Amazon but that's all I
have for you guys on Amazon
make sure comment down below what you
would like me to cover
next also if this liked this video they
measure up alike and consider
subscribing you cleric see more videos
just like this one but until then I'm
Hari I'll see you guys on next one
[Music]